yeah so um how are we telling the story
we have a website that's the primary
portal of communication for so many
people and entities these days National
Geographic calm / Genographic you can go
into the website find out what it is
we're doing what the project is all
about you can decide to participate you
can order a kit swab your own cheek see
how you fit into this growing family
tree become part of this massive
database but that's the primary means of
communication then of course you know
the one of the real benefits of working
in National Geographic is we have all
these these media outlets so we have the
National Geographic Channel and we're
making documentaries and we have the
magazine and we can tell stories through
the magazine and you know we have
dot-com which has a news site so it can
you know publicize the the new
scientific findings and then of course
there's the general media and then you
know the scientific results clearly are
published in the peer-reviewed
scientific literature but yeah I mean
it's it's using the media as a means of
communication to educate people so it's
not an ivory tower project at all it's
it's very much a project in the public
domain that's meant to educate people as
well as make discoveries
I spend a lot of my time on the road
more than half of it these days and have
been to some interesting places I guess
I've been to about 60 or 70 countries
now some of the more interesting places
have been for instance the Russian Far
East chukotka i was there in november
and it got down to minus 70 celsius in
the morning which is just ridiculously
cold I mean if you've ever been in
temperatures like that you know what I'm
talking about it's almost like the power
of a wave washing over you in the ocean
when you step outside you can just feel
the cold start to permeate your body and
you know that if you don't cover up and
you don't get back inside pretty quickly
you will die so that's amazing and you
know to see people living out in these
conditions and pulling their gloves off
and tying together little sinews on
their sleds to repair them and you know
just amazing to see people living in
those conditions a lot of the work we do
is in very poor places a lot of the
world's indigenous people are the
poorest of the poor and already poor
parts of the world and they live in very
remote locations many of which have been
subject to battle civil wars invasions
whatever it might be so it's not always
the safest job you know I've worked in
minefields and northern Chad and you
know places along the Afghan border
where the Taliban were you know making
advances at towns that were just a few
miles away and you know you do sometimes
take risks but there are calculated
risks and their risks that allow you to
get out and work with these you know
fascinating people who you know as I
mentioned before many of these groups
are disbanding they're moving away their
children are not going to be part of the
the culture anymore they're going to
enter the dominant culture and you know
the it's a tremendous opportunity and
you know just just an amazing chance to
be able to go out and see the world's
cultures before in a way they're gone
you know I've Airy much in cognizant
sometimes as I'm traveling to some of
these remote and dangerous places you
know you are so lucky to be able to do
this yes it's uncomfortable sometimes
yes you have to eat some kind of dodgy
food and it's it may not taste good yes
you may get sick yes you may be shot at
perhaps or there may be a rich
of running over a land mine or whatever
it is but my god when you get out to
these places and you see some of these
people and talk to them about their way
of life and you realize that you're kind
of glimpsing something that may not
exist in a generation or so you know you
just you kind of say wow I'm incredibly
lucky to be alive at this